guys I'm gonna share with you just
random stuff sometimes with these shorts
and I just wanted to share with you this
is the studio I was just sitting here
and filming and um something just
happened
I'm doing batch filming right so two two
three four sometimes even five if I have
a lot of energy videos in a day
and so I did a few videos and I just
realized that the audio is not working
so that means I have to do
it all again and I wanted to share this
with you because sometimes people just
share their lives and everything looks
so perfect on Instagram or on the videos
and I don't want to be one of those guys
I want to share the truth with you we
also have our struggles and our issues
and the team is working incredibly hard
behind the scenes where actually might
be almost late for this week because the
videos are longer and we're putting it
in a lot of effort so I'm just sending
this out there to ask you guys to pray
for us as a team we definitely need it
I'm not going to let the devil get me
down I'm gonna do this again because I
remember
I'm doing this for Christ and to save
lives I'll see you in the next video
cheers